does it ever become lonely being so
unpopular in your viewpoints yes alright
welcome back to another edition of
devil's advocate
I'm your host here scholar and today we
have a very special guest who has a very
lengthy resume that he wanted me to read
for me I worked at ABC 20/20 Fox News a
lot of books so he's written you can
follow him online at John Stossel
dot-com and of course he has channels
all over social media
Stossel TV dr. John Stossel thanks for
uh thanks for taking the time I'm not a
doctor okay so Johnny it is we're gonna
be talking today about single-payer
health care this was I believe I by your
request that's a hot button issue for
you correct you're one of many okay
right I know you fancy yourself more of
a libertarian so not really like a
populist sort of conservative I just
want to make sure off the bat I'm not
getting anything correct or
misrepresenting your views yes I'm a
pure libertarian okay so what would you
say is your primary issue Dinos a
libertarian I would presuppose being
interested in human rights and personal
liberties what would be your issue with
what would be a vast improvement over a
current health care system single-payer
healthcare well by single-payer you mean
the government just pays for everything
well I think that's a bit reductive and
oversimplification but a single-payer
option where the government could
provide an option for affordable health
care for yea the most vulnerable among
us let's go with that well I thought we
have that we spend a trillion dollars a
year on health care for the poor okay so
that in your estimation why does not
everyone have affordable health care in
this country because when everything
seems to be free it gets screwed up
horribly and the only thing that works
anywhere in any consumer transaction is
it the free market and we're not even
close
that healthcare were already heavily
socialized and you idiots want to make
it worse
I think that would be trick well we're
only two minutes in out of the gate with
a name-calling
I wouldn't want wouldn't want to go in
for a check-up with you as my doctor let
me ask you um you meant that either no
I'm glad we both agree on the free
market right now if I'm not mistaken
especially what's the repeal of certain
policies from the Affordable Care Act
from none other than the near President
President Trump the free market doesn't
seem to be working costs are going up
you can correct me if I'm wrong there
but if the free market is so effective
and we're the most free-market health
care economy why is there health care
more expensive here as a percentage of
GDP than like socialized countries all
using because we invent stuff and we
have a bureaucratic government that
makes everything costs more already the
only thing that really makes a market
work is when the individual spends his
own money in health care seven out of
eight dollars are spent either by the
government or private insurance
companies and you can call them private
but it's the worst form of capitalism
because they're making decisions for all
their customers and then well many
people want to cheat them and so they
spent a lot of time and money on
paperwork trying to stop cheating and
all that makes things cost more that's
part of it
the other reason is the rest of the
world free loads off our innovation oh
really how's that we invent the drugs
then they copy them and use them we
invent the best technology and that's
expensive and the government makes it
more expensive because it takes 10 to 12
years to get a drug approved sure well
listen I certainly wouldn't dispute that
more drugs are invented here and
certainly under this capitalist economy
that the pharmaceutical companies make a
lot of money but well I don't really see
it as a virtue and people's lives are at
stake
people's lives are always at stake and
I'm really glad that when I'm in pain a
pharmaceutical company may have invented
something that'll make it better and if
that costs more so
be it yeah sometimes it costs an opioid
addiction but whatever let's get to the
libertarian side of things here you're
all about you basic human rights and a
second Amendment obviously a big freedom
guy why do you not consider health care
a fundamental human right as a
libertarian take gun rights that's a
right to be left alone and have a gun
free speech is a right to speak sure
right to healthcare means you're saying
you have a right to force other people
to pay for your care that's very
different how is it different from say
car insurance I paid for my own car
insurance also incur insurance insurance
companies are allowed to price the
insurance according to your risk if I
have a lot of accidents or if I'm just
17 years old they charge more if I'm a
man they charge more because while we
men think we drive better we get do get
into more accidents right that's only
just that's insurance but with health
insurance because of your foolish
politician friends you're not allowed to
discriminate as they call it against
women or people with pre-existing
conditions that's not insurance that's
welfare so you think would be fixed if
we could I just wanna make sure I
understand this if we be discriminate
against women that's what would fix the
current health care epidemic these
insurance companies could charge women
more because women go to the doctor much
more often and incur far higher costs
then insurance would be real insurance
it wouldn't fix anything no sure well
the reason to bring up car insurance is
because yes you pay for it but you are
required to purchase car insurance I do
appreciate you recognizing that
particularly white males commit more car
are involved in more Coxon so clearly
not pulled over as often so I'm sure
you've you've recognized that about
yourself but you are by law required to
purchase car insurance of course in in
most states if you want to drive an
automobile vehicle so why would we not
apply that basic principle to
to people's lives and healthcare the
principle behind being forced to buy car
insurance is that if any responsible
person like save you crashes into me and
I incur terrible costs and you don't
have insurance I'm just screwed so
governments I'm not saying it's a good
idea require us to buy liability
insurance sure and if people shouldn't
have to buy casualty insurance that
cover the cost of our own cars and we
shouldn't have to buy health insurance
to cover our own bodies sure I
understand that in theory um I know
capitalists often like to act as a
socialist and students of people like
like Marx and Lenin really live in Syria
but it does seem as though you're living
in Syria as opposed to the real world
where health care costs if someone
doesn't have insurance if they're not
forced to purchase insurance it ends up
being more costly down the line so if
someone doesn't purchase health
insurance and someone catastrophic
happens we end up with the epidemic of
the United States spending more as a
part of their GDP right on health care
not to mention the quality of care we'll
get into that in a second don't don't
get me wrong we'll get to that in a
second but we spend more on average as a
part of our GDP then places like say
Norway or Canada and that's because a
lot of people don't purchase health
insurance it's because people don't buy
health insurance
the spending includes insurance and
out-of-pocket costs I don't see how
whether they buy health insurance makes
a difference well if you don't see it
and there's no explaining it to you
let's move on to quality of care um with
all this money going around obviously in
choice and free market as you put it why
is the United States have worse health
care than places like in the UK it
doesn't been ranked in the top ten I
mean that's that's pretty empirical
empirical according devil well says we
have worse health care well if you look
at national indexes and ratings
according to people who use the health
care the United States health care is
not rated as highly as places like
Canada and places a lot of single-payer
systems so you know well studies by some
smart some foolish people have concluded
that we spend
a ton of money and yet we die younger
and the reason for that however compared
say to Norway or Switzerland is not
because our health care is inferior it's
because we drive less
we drive more we shoot each other more
often and more of us are fat if you take
out obesity and car accidents and
gunshot injuries and deaths we live
longer than people in most other
countries if you take out the underclass
in America the group of people who have
been taught by the welfare state to
become dependent who are often obese who
don't take care of themselves
well then Americans live longer than
most anyone Wow that didn't take very
long to turn around a national crisis
and blame it on the vulnerable welfare
recipients that was fast you think you
think this is we're here at this problem
right now because of people who need a
leg up with Social Security no but I
think the statistic about why Americans
don't live as long as people in other
countries is because we're fat we drive
more and we shoot each other more often
and because we have an underclass well
I'm not talking about just a more I'm
not telling mortality I'm talking about
the quality of care as rated by polls
polls after poll after poll shows people
in other countries are more satisfied
with their care than the United States
for crying out loud I mean I think
Michael Moore addresses Cuba people are
more satisfied with their level of care
than the United States how does that
happen for the greatest country in the
world granted with all the shootings and
obesity as he just mentioned but let's
go with the moniker greatest country in
the world well why doesn't Michael moved
to Cuba and track when he want when it
went to get his stomach what's it called
his intestines tied to lose weight he
didn't go to Cuba for their heritage
health care you went to a private clinic
the Cubans
claim their health care is better and
they convinced usefully use
idiots like you what well it's not true
ice they lie about everything else
why would wouldn't they lie about this
so people like so we're towing Cuba and
by the way I saw that I saw you did
there I saw how you picked one country
and chose to ignore the other it's very
very good sleight of hand let's take
Cuba out but the UK Canada people more
satisfied with their health care than
the United States doesn't that matter if
we're talking about quality why do we
not have health care that is to the
standards of these people or
particularly like in the Scandinavian
countries when we have more resources in
any country it seems to notice has
fallen apart well you loved a lot of
stuff together there but people in those
countries say that they like their
systems because when the pollsters ask
them most people aren't sick and when
you're not sick and you know that you'll
just be taken care of
you're pretty happy with the system when
you are sick and say in Britain you get
put in the emergency room left in the
hall for two or three days and just read
the British newspapers they say they're
in crisis it distracted by you yeah it
seems seems like you do you what you say
distracted I say um sin li veiled
argument so it seems like you're preying
on fear here right doctors docile fear
of the British newspapers fear of
mortality rates being higher survival
rates being on your left in the hallway
and not getting treatment when I'm
really sick you know I'm scared of that
but you're you you're worth playing what
40 million dollars I don't think it's a
problem it might might be a problem that
the vilified welfare recipient who you
addressed earlier might have to face but
mister never pulled over doctor Stossel
might not really need to be afraid of
that so coming leaves a disingenuous
arguments maybe at the door I'm think
it's disingenuous you brought up England
and Canada and they have great health
care as long as you don't need it but if
you need it you may be in the hallway
for a long time and you made
before you get care dinner on Paul
assume that you have like a bronze
statue of him in your in your study
there I didn't run Paul go to Canada to
have a procedure done Rand Paul his son
did and he went to private clinic and
Canada
unlike the system proposed by Bernie
Sanders and camel Harris allows
competing private insurance and private
medical practice and he found a good one
for his particular problem and went to
use it so I noticed a trend here you
mentioned Bernie Sanders there Camilla
Harris and then I mean esteemed very you
know steamed members of the United
States government
now you mentioned welfare recipients all
of whom would represent minorities in
the country do you think it may be of a
blind-spot that maybe your views in
health care could be perhaps a little
racist come on Harris reason has to do
with this come on well it just seems the
people that you're upset with right
Kamal Harris Bernie Sanders obviously of
Jewish descent welfare recipients tend
to be people who are often minorities as
your donald trump has pointed out seems
to me your problems tend to be with
people in minority classes no not not to
my knowledge
okay well not my donald trump no i
didn't vote
where am i voted for the libertarian
who's a Gary Jones Gary Johnson that's
right that's right no because you smoke
a lot of pot and stuff I get it a lot of
people wanted to Gary Johnson well good
good good good for you I hope that you
feel really good about yourself getting
Trump elected voting for Greg Johnson I
feel happier that it's Trump than
Hillary although Donald Trump is a
really horrible venal narcissistic
immature dangerous person but I'm still
glad he's president rather than Hillary
you say that with a smirk what was that
why you mean you mentioned all these
negative qualities I agree with you on
President Trump but then how is he
better than
and I wasn't a Hillary fan obviously I
was Bernie all the way but I don't see
how that's superior because to me you
asked the very beginning
what's my issue my issue is thomas
jefferson's he said it's the natural
progress of things for government to
grow and liberty to yield in this
country succeeded because the founders
created an environment where most
decisions were left to individuals and
we grew the fastest and went from a poor
place to the richest country in the
world when government was less than 5%
of GDP now it's 40 and constantly
climbing and only doesn't eclipse the
private sector because the private
sector has been grown and Hillary would
have made that worse her people would
have smothered us with a million little
rules and that really would screw poor
people and minorities yeah seems to
really be true in people and in places
like Norway and Denmark and in Canada
but it's always interesting to me that
people point to Jefferson and he uses
you know talking about Liberty growing
and planting freedom a lot easier to do
that when you're people doing your your
planting and your soul tilling or slaves
right the slavery was bad slavery is bad
Jefferson was wrong about that but that
doesn't make him wrong about everything
and Norway does pretty well because they
are a small country with a huge amount
of oil yeah well I'm glad to hear you
say slavery is bad at least we agree on
that something that seems most Americans
agree on and this is something I find
curious considering that you're a
libertarian and I know that you're not a
big fan is you've mentioned of
centralized government bureaucrats so it
seems to me that you would at least be
familiar with the precept of democracy
70% of American citizens want
single-payer health care 70% why does
that know why do we want to leave that
in the hands of a few people in what the
swamp as your folks call it why should
they make a decision that flies in the
face of what 70% of Americans want we
shouldn't leave it in the hand of the
swamp the best system is were in
Jools pay for their own healthcare and
doctors make their own decision about
what they charge and I'm sure 70 percent
want that and 70 percent including most
Republicans support a minimum wage and
nevertheless they're all bad ideas Wow
there's a switch you're against any sort
of a minimum wage I want to get back to
health care but that's just yes
obviously pretty uh pretty intense for
no minimum wage at all I'm assuming this
goes back to your disdain for members of
welfare recipients well actually minimum
wages were passed initially to hurt
black people who were coming up from the
south and competing with white laborers
and so white legislators passed minimum
wage laws to protect white people but
the country grew fastest when employers
and workers were free to make their own
deal and that's the best system in your
estimation what do you think yeah but
you think the average wage would be
higher if corporations had their way
right now that a minimum wage I mean is
that actually that's what I believe the
economy would be so free and energetic
and the animal spirits of capitalism
would lift all boats
most people would make more then why
isn't that the case it returns to health
care which is privatized which we have
and we have insurance companies here we
do not have a socialized system why has
that not raised all boats when
deductibles and premiums are going up
and it's becoming on a for an affordable
for the average American family I'm not
seeing the free market really helping
them out here doctor with your
assumptions are wrong it's not private
it's socialized how could it be private
if seven out of eight dollars are spent
by somebody else
seven out of eight dollars where are you
getting that statistic you mean seven
out of a total dollars in health care in
the United States are being spent by the
government is what you're saying
government and private insurance
companies okay well okay so that still
would if the vast majority of the seven
out of eight would be private insurance
companies that's still a private
business model
it's the worst kind of private business
model it's the only thing that works is
when you pay you make the decision and
we see this now with health savings
accounts where the government allows you
to put some to say to pay your employees
a certain amount into a savings account
a medical savings account but they can
spend as they want and John Mackey of
Whole Foods tried this it was surprised
to see the reaction among his employees
they at first were nervous but then
started to go to doctors and say hey
doctor I really need that MRI or is
there a cheaper place to get it and do I
have to must this test cost $200 and the
doctors often would ask well how are you
gonna pay I'm gonna pay cash doctor
would say really and you don't have to
wait I won't have to wait two months
until the insurance company pays me well
then maybe $100 and they wouldn't even
know where to put it because they
haven't had a cash box in doctors
offices for years but that system brings
costs down and makes patients think
which parts of healthcare do I really
want a you understand this because
you're not an old geezer like me but I
get Medicare now I go to the doctor and
nobody even talks about price I never
asked the doctor never mentions I'm sure
I get tests that I might not need
because the normal price signals that
make every other market work don't work
in medicine so you are taking advantage
of Medicare but you would be against for
example Medicare for all which would
seem like a common-sense solution that I
know people like Bernie and and Cortese
have proposed they should take mine away
along with everybody else okay so let's
say they but you're using it so
obviously being facetious you're using
Medicare if they're good the
government's gonna hand out money if
they're gonna give me a deduction for my
mortgage I'm gonna take it and how would
you compare your quality of care with
Medicare versus private insurance
companies would you say you're satisfied
sometimes sometimes not I I don't see a
difference between Medicare and private
insurance companies when I go to the
doctor the doctor doesn't ask who's
gonna pay until afterwards right but you
didn't mentioned for example a procedure
maybe costing $100 or a few hundred
dollars and you throw those numbers
around what about people who cannot
afford that
you're suggesting to them would be hey
just pay cash cuz I don't like Medicare
I mean that's still very expensive what
if someone has a catastrophic health
care event what what if they get cancer
I mean they can't pay for these things
out-of-pocket you're talking about
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
treatment let's let's get real here
right bro first the reason it's hundreds
of thousands of dollars for treatment
cause they're getting very new and
special care that didn't exist before
and only because it costs a lot our
companies willing to spend the billion
dollars to bring that treatment or drug
to market but secondly you've heard of
Medicaid right we do spend a trillion
dollars on poor people in America and as
a libertarian I be happy to say get rid
of that too because if we didn't have
this behemoth government making all
these decisions then private charities
would step in and take care of the food
and before we had this welfare system we
had enormous numbers of Catholic
Charities Jewish charities non-religious
charities who took care of people
we had 14,000 mutual aid societies and
they were often racist it was White's
helping White's Koreans helping Koreans
blacks helping blacks but they knew
better who needed help and who needed a
kick in the butt most disappeared when
government took it over
but if government disappeared tomorrow
private groups would spring in and do
the job better well it seems like I'm
hearing some conflicting evidence from
you because you said before private
charities were taking care of people
before the government intervened but now
you're talking about all of the
expanding medical innovation that's
taking place in this country since
government intervention so so which is
that
or the big welfare state as you call it
that we had more medical innovation or
the government helping with this has it
actually shown to to increase
productivity and creating new drugs and
life-saving medicine no it doesn't
increase productivity innovation was
happening just as fast or faster before
now you could say some of the government
funding for basic research has sped
innovation but that's a tiny percentage
of what government spends on health care
whereas most of their money go spending
that if not on innovation right you say
seven out of eight dollars is spent by
someone else we're dedicating Medicare
treatments the government pays for
people and you would do away with that
it paid for it ourselves yeah I'm sure
you you would do away with that which
seems like quite a bit of a roll of the
dice with people's lives that if we did
away with government it seems to me that
your argument here and correct me if I'm
wrong is if we did away with Medicare
and Medicaid and we wanted to go back to
privatization hopefully some Catholics
and race racist Koreans would take care
of it how about right yeah that's about
right
and obviously it's not gonna happen and
it would take time before the private
charities would step up but if the
government had stepped up in the first
place there would be vast private
charities running hospitals offering all
kinds of health care innovation think
about the Great Depression
how poor America was them vast twenty
four percent unemployment people really
had no money how many people star
practically no one because there were
all these private charities government
killed them seems that more people were
starving than without some kind of
government intervention like if you look
at the model Cities program or what
we're doing now more people were
starving in the Great Depression than
today wouldn't you agree
best I could do the research we found
reports in a few states of 24 people who
allegedly starved during the growth
Great Depression
I assume now nobody stars that's true
now we're vastly richer nobody should
start well there yes so that's that's
progress and I'll be proof positive that
government programs do work they do help
fewer people are starving now because
there's government infrastructure in
place to make sure that they have you
know a hot meal and clothes on their
backs hooray well Thursday the opposite
is true
fewer people starve as the country got
richer because private enterprise made
us richer in spite of the welfare state
okay so in spite of it it happened it
correlates exactly to the increase of
the welfare state but it's in spite of
it because there's also private
companies right is that good enough or
ladies exactly the existence of the
welfare state that didn't begin until
the 1960s and health improved greatly in
America before all this government
intervention well right now you know I
think something that's important we
talked about the free market is that
claims are often denied when you're
dealing with insurance companies so
unlike unions or workplaces where
there's some kind of collective
bargaining power there is no bargaining
power with insurance companies so I get
that you don't want the welfare state I
get that you want to do a with Medicare
and Medicaid but would we not agree that
making it to where no claims are denied
under the current system that that's
fair no people would claim all kinds of
stuff people people my age think that
they're just getting back from Social
Security and Medicare what we paid in
that FICA deduction in our checks but
but average we get triple what we paid
in because we rudely refused to die and
we keep living longer and I present this
and in doing videos to old people in
rich retirement communities in Florida
and people say things like what you
can't get rid of Medicare there goes my
social life look people go hang out in
doctors offices because somebody else
will pay we're already going broke in
America and this is just a recipe to
speed it up so let me ask us to give you
the floor
little confused forgive me I'm not a
doctor but let me ask you how would you
solve the current healthcare crisis that
sounds like you're not a fan of
insurance companies but you're also not
a fan of single-payer if if dr. Johnson
talks a lot his way how would this work
out what would you do you could wave
your magic wand wow it's not a question
I often get because it's just not gonna
happen
we would have big health savings
accounts the tax law would change so
that it didn't encourage employers to
buy catastrophic health insurance for
people that we would make our own
decisions there would be a competing
health insurance market and smart people
would only buy insurance against the
really big cost that they couldn't
afford and most health care spending
would be done the way we spend on our
iPhones and food we paid for it
ourselves costs would stop rising
innovation would increase do you have
any examples of this kind of a model
working anywhere in a pragmatic sense no
and no country as a pure free market
system except poor countries and they
are floor in a million way the countries
often cited is single-payer like France
Germany Switzerland are not they have
private insurance and people pay out of
their own pocket for a lot of things
Americans don't realize that but the
idea since Bismarck in Germany that
somebody else should pay for your health
care took over all the advanced
countries of the world and it just grows
and it just so you believe that everyone
who agrees with that premise including
all of well most of Europe 70 percent of
Americans that people should share the
burden of health care costs in your
estimation what are they just are they
just delusional like they're not I don't
underst when it's overwhelming does it
ever become lonely being so unpopular
and your view
yes oh that does okay so what would you
say these really 70% of Americans in
Europe who they all believe in the illa
systems based around shouldering the
burden together of the costs they're
just all wrong yeah they're all wrong
and they don't realize that shouldering
it together means over time innovation
slows some people abuse the system and
everyone is worse off eventually they
realize it just as your folks in
Venezuela are real is realizing that now
oh come on
oh that's just such a cheap trick you
know that that's all people I say your
folks and they point to the worst
example of socialism fair criticism like
I shouldn't have said I don't think I
don't mean I don't know can you point to
any mainstream American leftist
politicians or figures who supported
Venezuela or Chavez yeah Michael Moore
you mentioned him earlier okay that's
better I just saw this video of Bernie
Sanders singing and the Soviet Union
with his wife they went there on their
honeymoon a little X said long believed
in state planet yeah I'll admit the
optics aren't good the masking that's
going back to the idea of being a human
right you know certain things are basic
fundamental human rights as a
libertarian you obviously believe let me
ask you this what do you believe are
fundamental rights in the United States
let's let's not go global but what is a
human right because I think maybe that's
wrong or not we're missing each other
that every person has a right to be left
alone to have other people and the
government not hurt them or take their
stuff as a libertarian I do not agree
with some of my pure libertarian friends
who say that's all government should do
I think we should also have pollution
control rules as there's no good market
incentive for me to have a factory that
doesn't pollute your air on
government steps in to take care of that
and otherwise that's it those are right
to be left alone and forge our own lives
so things like police roads you don't
think the government should be doing
things like roads you don't use roads
police is local government and you have
people band together and say we ought to
have a police force and again right not
to be physically hurt or have people
take your stuff that ought to be a basic
right most are the big roads the best
roads in America where we're built by
private contractors people don't know
that I'm here in New York City where
everybody talks about the subway as an
example government has to build the
subways because it just no capitalist
would find a way to make money yeah
people don't know that most of the
subways in New York City were built
privately and then taken over by the
government because the politicians were
outraged they wanted to raise the fare
from five cents to ten cents and now the
fare is about three bucks when
government runs it worse but the private
sector will do a lot of these things
better yeah what about the buses in New
York that is a government some are and
some are not okay most most are going
and they're not so great it's impossible
to get fired just about your bad bus
driver Oh for a bus driver I was gonna
say yeah as a passenger they can kick
you off quite promptly Oh
Penn Station they're a couple of times I
don't see that happening very often but
sure preneur is mostly immigrants
started Vance Vance service to
supplement the government bus service in
parts of New York and the city and the
bus drivers unions got the government to
penalize them and in some cases ban them
government doesn't like competition
especially competition that serves
people better for less so I guess kind
of final a couple of questions here you
mentioned having the right to not be
hurt by someone else do you think that's
a legitimate role of government correct
physically
okay so physically hurt so let's change
that to okay it's the government's job
to make sure that someone's not hitting
you right with a baton or whatever
before the gun laws got crazy out of
control and we have the mass shootings
that we have now in record scale but
let's just say okay everything
physically hurt scale oh yes things are
not ah there's just more media coverage
oh yeah well tell that to the victims of
Sandy Hook and in Vegas and you know but
hey different strokes I doesn't I
wouldn't necessarily recipients all
right so let's just change this to
someone hitting you and assaulting you
it's the government's right it's their
duty their job a legitimate role for
them to step in and protect you now
change that person hitting you to for
example a pharmaceutical company or an
insurance company taking advantage of
somebody denying a claim making drugs or
services unaffordable so that that
person is we're talking a very real
physical harm facing death in the
absence of fundamental health care yeah
very different they're not hitting me
they're saying I made this thing and you
can't have it unless you pay me and they
have every right to do that so how would
you help these people who for example
can't afford it people who can't afford
this care and they're just okay
your alternative for them to to die and
decrease the surplus population I'm
trying to understand how this works in a
real in a real world setting people need
health care some people can't get it
what do you do with them two things will
help one if you let the market work the
prices will come down so they can afford
most everything and secondly private
charity will among people private area
and that's where we go back to the new
Koreans helping Koreans and the blacks
and helping blacks and white to help and
Weiss this is this is a john stossel
utopia for America I just want to make
sure that we're not getting why
Americans are pretty generous I I gave a
lot of money to Gerry's last year and I
think we who have done well in life want
to help
people and will well how would you
explain in the rich just keep getting
richer and the poor keep getting poor
and the middle class is disappearing if
that's the case that all those
assumptions are wrong the middle class
is disappearing because more of them
were becoming rich the rich are getting
absurdly rich mostly because the stock
market keeps going up but the poor
aren't getting poor the average income
has gone up not as much as the rich but
it's gone up plus where people have
access to things like iPhones which make
their lives better
created by capitalism yeah perfect isn't
one of the choices
yeah that's great yeah people now have
addictions to their phones because of
capitalism and we see that as a success
I don't know that I would agree with you
any closing thoughts on on socialized
healthcare where people can go to hear
more of your arguments if there's
anything that you would like to leave
people with that have gotten incorrect
because I want to recap I think that
healthcare is a human right I believe in
not letting people die and being
compassionate and you just want people
to buy health care and if they can to
died have that about right you can final
word final word is that I congratulate
you and that even though I have a hunch
that steven crowder is behind you um you
get me going in this process get me
worked up secondly every week I make a
short video that does a much more
articulate job than I've done today
arguing these points and I hope your
listeners can find that and where would
they find that I don't obviously I want
to be generous here with the with the
plug's council stossel TV just google it
Stossel TV Stossel TV and that's on
Facebook YouTube and John I also believe
just that john stossel dot-com and what
was it what was your PhD and what was
that dr. Stossel no PhD I already sort
of waste of money for most
non-intellectual people like me okay so
not dr. stossel john stossel dot-com
thank you very much this has been
devil's advocate Skeletron your host we
provide the information you decide we'll
see you soon
guys thank you how do we get out and I
hope you enjoyed the segment we've done
it quite a few times believes it's the
fourth or fifth time and you know it
allows us to really shine a light on the
the alt-right a conservative right
whatever they want to call themselves
today and you can hear arguments from
both sides watch one of these videos
playing a box next to me subscribe hit
the notification bell so that you'll be
notified of any future installments and
yeah we're really hoping to get on
YouTube bread and just waiting for green
light from what just skate so we're
doing pretty well